with world leaders gathered together in
glasgow to discuss the climate emergency
this week all eyes are on the biggest
polluters it's been six years since the
landmark paris agreement when almost 200
countries agreed to combat rising
temperatures and the scorecard is bad
most countries are failing to reduce
emissions fast enough
so there was great interest when prime
minister of india narendra modi took the
stage this is the statement that got
everyone's attention quote by 2070 india
will achieve the target of net zero
emissions
he also listed a five-point plan to put
india on the pathway to net zero modi
says india will meet the following
milestones in the next nine years by
2030.
india will increase its non-fossil fuel
energy capacity to 500 gigawatts it will
transition to 50 renewable energy
sources it will reduce projected carbon
emissions by 1 billion tons and reduce
the economy's carbon intensity by 45
all to reach carbon zero by 2070. here's
one climate strategist reaction who is
optimistic about modi's promises the
prime minister has set india firmly on a
clean energy pathway
this can deliver net zero definitely by
2017 uh but hopefully india can achieve
it much earlier just to give you an
example we are asked away from 2070 as
1970 was from behind us and i can assure
you
no one would have predicted the level of
transition that has already taken place
in india currently
but is that optimism realistic let's get
more from dw's environment reporter ajit
naranjan who is in glasgow at the moment
ajit we just heard from a commentator
who argues that modi's pledges are
strong what do you make of modi's
alleged commitments
so the commitment to end greenhouse gas
emissions to get them to net zero by
2070 is a big step forward in india's
ambitions on climate change and what
we've heard from analysts
and climate scientists is that this is
actually a very promising first step
because what climate scientists have
shown very clearly is that for the world
to keep temperatures at 1.5 degrees
celsius by the end of the century
something they pledged to do in the
paris agreement six years ago
then the world needs to level out its
co2 emissions by 2050 and its greenhouse
gas emissions by 2070.
now modi's pledged to sort out the first
the
half of that about greenhouse gases by
2070 what he hasn't been clear on is
what that means for carbon dioxide
emissions by 2050 whether that would
also be the case
if so it would mean that his targets are
consistent with the paris agreement what
we're also hearing though is that the
targets for 2030 that we just heard are
much more important if india does really
manage to build out that much renewable
energy to cut its co2 emissions then
that will put it in good stead to
actually continue follow through with
this and
turn its economy which is very heavily
co-dependent into one that's actually
climate friendly
right and you might have noticed i just
said earlier alleged commitments because
world leaders have promised many things
at these climate change conferences over
the years and failed to deliver so how
reliable are the pledges that have been
made
so that's the thing about these climate
conferences these are promises these are
pledges and they have been broken before
most notably in 2009 at the copenhagen
summit rich countries promised promised
poorer ones 100 billion us dollars a
year in climate finance to help them
green their economies to help them adapt
to the effects of climate change
but that never came through last year
they did not meet that target and now
we're seeing we're going to have
negotiations all of today to kind of
haggle over that sum of money to come up
with a credible plan to fulfill that
promise belatedly
and so pledges are one thing and it's
why climate scientists that we speak to
are consistently stressing
countries need to do things now they
need to act immediately to burn fewer
fossil fuels they need plans that are
credible for 2025 2030. and these will
help them get to these nice net zero
targets by the middle of the century or
a bit later but that's not where the
focus necessarily needs to be
right
well if you stand by ajit we'll have
more questions in just a moment a moment
but i want to go to this next report
about india's conundrum because so many
people there depend on coal take a look
for these workers in india's east
coal is the only source of income
without it they say they would die
if we can't do this and we will starve
we'll have to beg
coal has saved so many poor people after
selling sex of coal we can feed
ourselves
this couple are also among the thousands
of informal workers in the state who
need coal to stay alive
they earn three dollars a day by
scavenging coal and selling it to
traders
in this community there are few other
options
[Music]
there's no arable land here
only coal stone and fire nothing else
coal plays a vital role in india's
economy
powering 75 percent of its electricity
generation
and while the country has made progress
in developing renewables
it says it needs coal to meet its vast
energy requirements
and is planning to open more plants
the livelihoods of millions of people
and businesses
are also connected to the industry
coal is really an ecosystem
right
while you know the primary purpose of
coal extraction is to power to provide
energy
uh but really like you know when
uh
when when coal industries operate and
they operate in certain pockets of india
they create lots of jobs
direct indirect
it also provides revenues
to various
state governments
district governments
and also the
central government
delhi says without coal it will be
unable to raise living standards for its
people or fuel economic growth as the
west has already done
they also point out that the average
indian still uses less coal than their
counterparts in the united states and
germany
but with fossil fuels now clearly
identified as the driver of disastrous
climate change the question now is
whether india will act in time
or leave the problem to the next
generation
i mean what you see is tension between
emerging economies and developed
countries
who needs to do more
so
the developed economies have
been
emitting fossil emit burning fossil
fuels and emitting co2 historically that
have caused the majority of this problem
what people don't necessarily realize is
that even though big countries like
china and india are big emitters today
there's still a historical carbon debt
that rich countries in theory would pay
poorer countries in order to kind of
equal things out now the paris climate
agreement addresses this partly rich
countries signed up to have these common
but differentiated responsibilities
and if they were to actually deliver on
this it would mean acknowledging that
they would have to have more ambitious
climate targets
and
cut their fossil fuel usage earlier and
that's what a lot of poorer countries
are calling for at this conference
what's unclear though is what that means
for the poorer countries themselves many
of which are burning fossil fuels like
coal as we just heard which have a huge
negative which really hurt their own
citizens it causes huge problems for
mortality causes lung cancer and so on
and so there's an interest at home
domestically to actually sort this
problem out as well even beyond what
we're hearing on the international stage
here
right and of course the key point is of
course mother nature doesn't keep score
it doesn't really matter what the
historical past
you know determined in terms of the
developed country's responsibilities we
have a climate emergency ajit naranjan
thank you so much for joining us
thank you very much
you